Je joue mes 3 dernières dates de spectacle en Décembre 2016 aux Zénith de Pariiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiis Venez
J'aime plus trop ce mot "Draguer"
parce que ça fait un peu forceur
Moi ce dont j'ai envie de vous parler c'est  la séduction naturelle
d'ailleurs j'ai failli appeler cette vidéo "La séduction naturelle"...
Mais ça faisait un peu "film français de la Nouvelle Vague"
La Séduction Naturelle,
Un film de Jean-Luc Godard
Alors j'ai failli l'appeler "Séduire au naturel"
Mais, ça faisait un peu boite de thon
"Séduire, au naturel"
Du coup je l'appelle tout simplement "Techniques de drague 3"
Même si ça fait un peu Rocky
Pour séduire une femme, faut tout simplement être soi-même
discret, charmant, on est pas des sauvages, on est pas des chasseurs
"Le chasseur, il va avec son fusil, il chasse
Moi mon fusil de chasse, c'est le pc quoi"
*à par lui apparemment*
En vrai, quand tu veux plaire à une fille, on le sait tous, il y a rien de mieux que d'être un gentleman
des petits riens de galanteries, mine de rien ça peut tout changer
"Ha, attends
Madame.
Norman, c'est ma veste ça
Oui, ça c'est ta veste ouais, ça... ça c'est ta veste
Et j'te recouvre...absolument que tu la mette, parce que tu, tu vas avoir froid
Donc on disait...
Quand tu veux draguer, faut pas écouter les conseils des autres
La réponse, elle est dans ton coeur
Merci à tous
Pourtant on a tous ce pote, qui se prend pour Hitch, et qui veut te donner des conseils en séduction,
comme si t'étais un gros puceau
"Pour séduire les femmes, c'est hyper-simple, c'est la confiance en soi
Parce que, ce qu'elles veulent, c'est un putain de mâle, tout simplement."
Mais ce mec là t'as juste envie de lui dire
Je me disais, toi on t'a jamais vu avec une meuf ?
Ouais parce que moi en fait...
Excusez-moi. Bonjour !
Je vous ai vu là-bas et je voulais savoir si je pouvais avoir votre numéro ?
Mon numéro pour... coucher avec moi ?
Euh... faire l'amour ?
Faire l'amour... directement ? Moi je veux bien ?
Nan faut pas me toucher merci
La confiance en soi
c'est vraiment le B-A-BA
Je suis tombé sur des sites
qui explique à des mecs
quels comportements  à avoir pour séduire
mais les conseils qu'ils donnent sur ces sites
c'est quand même des grosses évidences
ça parait assez évident que c'est vraiment les pires arguments du monde pour draguer quoi
Tu sais les bons gros lourds bien beaufs ?
Qui interpellent des meufs dans la rue et puis qui les insultent ?
Je me disais: ces mecs-là ils se prennent tellement des gros râteaux tout le temps
que si un jour une meuf accepte...
ça va donner ça
Hé excuse-moi t'es bonne !
Ah tu trouves ? Ah ça me fait plaisir ?
Toi aussi t'es mignon !
Euh... bah en fait je suis jamais arrivé à cette étape
donc je sais pas quoi dire
Attends excuse-moi
Hé excuse-moi t'es bonne !
Sôlôpe
Autant moi dans le vie je suis nul pour faire des recherches sur Internet
Je sais pas, j'ai pas la fibre de la recherche
Mais quand il s'agit de retrouver sur Facebook une meuf que t'as croisé en soirée...
Alors là nous les mecs
on se transforme clairement en agent de la CIA
Ok les gars
je veux qu'on encercle tout le périmètre des amis en commun qu'on a avec elle
d'après nos meilleurs souvenirs avant qu'elle soit bourrée
elle portait un haut rouge avec des pois blancs
et des énormes seins
et son visage chef ?
elle avait des énormes seins
Ok d'après nos sources c'est la pote de la pote de la meuf qui organisait la soirée
Nos p'tits gars ont réussi à dénicher une vidéo amateur
Attendez...revenez en arrière
Faîtes un zoom x8
Faîtes 425/32
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne de Norman fait des vidéos
Chantez les premières notes de la vie en rose
Quand il me prend dans ses bras
Eclaircissez encore un peu l'image
Voilà ! C'est elle !
Mais chef, mais c'est ma femme ça !
Ok Bobby
On annule l'opération
Faîtes quand même une petite capture d'écran
Avec 2-3 feuilles de sopalin pour moi, pour le dossier des archives de...
de ma bite
La chute bien vulgaire qui va bien plaire à Papa et Maman
Quand une fille te plaît physiquement
C'est vrai que l'avis de tes potes sur son physique bizarrement il est assez important
Comme si on avait besoin d'une sorte de validation tu vois ?
*Vives les mariés ! Bravo !*
T'en penses quoi ?
Elle est pas ouf
En fait j'ai changé d'avis je casse
Tout le monde dragouille un peu sur Snapchat
T'envois un petit cœur, tu montres ta bite
ça fait plaisir
Par contre le mode vidéo il est très dangereux
Histoire vraie, récemment j'ai présenté une fille que j'aimais bien à mes potes via snap
Mais ils ont pas eu la réaction que j'attendais
Je vous présente Elodie
Raah elle est bonne
ça doit être une grosse cochonne
Euuh là elle nous voit en fait
Salut les garçons, ça va ??
Salut
Salut mon amour , je t'aime
Moi j'ai pas trop de conseils à donner en séduction
Par contre je peux vous déconseiller des trucs
Par exemple si vous comptez séduire une meuf à une soirée
Je vous déconseille d'y aller avec un pote trop beau
Tu sais ce mec que toutes les meufs kiffes, parce que à coter de lui à la soirée
Bah t'as juste l'air d'un meuble
Tu étais pas venu avec un gars la...
Ah tu parles de Norman ?
Norman
Ouais ouais, il est juste à coter, il est là
Salut
De toute façon, beau ou pas, tout ça c'est très superficiel
Et puis comme on dit, tous les gouts sont dans la nature
Donc peut importe votre physique, peut importe à quoi vous ressemblez
Dites-vous bien qu'un jour ou l'autre, vous tomberez forcement sur une femme qui vous correspond
Et sinon tu fais quoi dans la vie ?
Eh bah moi je suis chez IKEA depuis 2 ans là
Ohhhhhh trop mignon
Donc soutient à tous ceux comme moi qui sont de bon gros meuble en soirée
hashtag étagère, hashtag commode
Merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo, j'espère qu'on va se revoir très très bientôt hein parce que je vous aime tous
Mais genre à la folie
Non mais vraiment je suis amoureux
Donc j'espère à très vite et si ça vous a plut mettez un pouce en l'air pour l'amour du love